ja und ein hubschrauber und keine rolle
reimann keine drei meter hoch gute was
ist jetzt zu planen wenn man ganz lange
fährt kommt was wie kannst du dich
eigentlich bei solchen belgier
festhalten
die angeblich aber richtig lang fährt
dann geht es gegen mann untertan sprit
mehr wenn man zurück schwimmen will
kommt irgendwie ein highlight und frisst
ein auf das klingt aussprachen eindruck
der seriösen machen relativ sich
eigentlich als manches teil direkt aus
die hast gar nicht ist es dass jetzt die
nacht
da wusste ich auch nicht richtig kennt
ob es ja noch ein singleplayer und koop
multiplayer auf den täter noch immer das
festland blöd doch man sieht die
hochhäuser ganz klein bisschen am
horizont aber fordert man nichts ja das
wird glaube ich schon oder ähnlich wie
die relegation hat die grippe um ihr
fertiges sahen das echt klinisch prüfen
lassen einfach sterben wegen hersteller
ford kommt zurück
die langweiligste folge
nein aber ich hab nur halb gedreht
leger hier muss noch mal ansehen was
passieren aber heftig oder immer somit
rücken mit
das war oder dann kommt wo das einfach
alle
war das am anfang auch schon losgefahren
jetzt ist es nicht so ich habe
vibrationen aus wenn wir eine luft sind
es ist okay
da müsst ihr immer langsam
schließlich wird noch heftiger ehrlich
ja so ein bisschen schneller
ok oder das einfach ein vibrator ist
kein kultur ja ich hier über kurze was
keine ahnung
ja du also wenn jetzt in den nächsten
zehn sekunden nichts passiert dann will
ich das jetzt auch live aber auf jeden
fall
wir fahren auch irgendwie nicht mehr
weiter weg vom festland eventuell des
tableaus im wasser zum mond fahren alter
bist du dann konnte
berlin wenn wir uns wieder in the town
kein kann man zu zweit nehmen
ich habe mich ja irgendwie muss man
jedoch wenn man fliegt die die
rhede einklappen oder weil es sich dass
der fehler bei unserem escape aktion
dass man mit l2 l3 und ehre dieses
fahrwerk einkehren muss ja komm wir
versuchen gibt es eigentlich noch
irgendwo ja wir sollten auf dem
flughafen nicht unbedingt auf den
militärstützpunkt am flughafen haben den
zugriff und wo es der mann weg
wir sind fast am flughafen du fährst
weil direkt darauf zu
ja ich gucke dort auf die map
danke dass du weg abgesperrt ist das
bestimmt nicht legal wieder reingehen
jonas ja deswegen fest
hier ist alles abgesperrt
wo ich dann ganz getroffen habe und dann
doch nicht ja dass es läuft bei diesem
flug auf ich glaube die gefahren nicht
zu bieten
jetzt auch kein beach heißt quick quick
quick set ich hätte ganz gesund zu
sprinten und dann das handy rausgenommen
und walter dix gedrückt da habe ich
irgendwas wenn die ausgewählte junge
mann die kombinierte anders gespannt
aber hier ist mein auto insofern ich
komme nicht um mein auto ist immer noch
gut von mir du arsch ja ich komme hier
nicht rein
nicht ein ich glaube die ganze zeit
herum aber freunde ich finde wir können
jetzt mal wo ich jetzt diese am laufen
bin gar nicht thema besprechen und
können uns war anni wenn ich hier ist
einfach dann kommt
ich habe keinen hinterreifen danke luca
per kabel oder keinen hinterreifen ich
gern gemacht verdammte axt ich würde
meinem angeblich stirbt gleich wegen
ausdauer
ja ich komme gleich zu dir wir hier in
fragen habt ihr nicht keine reifen mehr
an geld ein bisschen schnelligkeit jetzt
ich kann ja nichts machen hier mutter
ganz ist oder soll ich mich einfach
umbringen das ist noch weg ich bin in
form vom flughafen eingang los ich muss
seit außen rum weil du auslöst ach
scheiße
das war nicht so klug ich hab mein auto
geklaut und flughafens über alter hier
fährt ein bus am flughafen er und ich
glaube auch nicht mehr abholen
jetzt aber eine heftige landebahn und
alles ja ja das ist wieder rein und hol
mich hier raus man mehr raus
ich glaube mein leben ich bin so einer
kacke drin ist es gut bei dir lass mal
einfach beide umbringen hoffen dass wir
eine gleichen links vorn da waren da ist
aber ich bin glaube ich gerade am ende
ja doch vielleicht ich weiß ich muss
gucken
ich laufe jetzt um die kurven wieder
bullerjahn halt so weil ich ein auto
mitgenommen habe flughafen
ja also halb ich sehe schon mal auf die
bühne
das sieht so aus als ob ist doch es ist
abgesperrt aber ich weiß nicht
vielleicht hab ich davon ja man kann da
vornherein nicht sehr ich sehe schon
eine durch lisa ja ja das sind auflieger
muss eigentlich nur durch die hauptstadt
anzufliegen und damit den freeway ich
glaub ich lasse nicht als wir sind jetzt
schon so nah dran
ich bin schon 1000 kilometer gelaufen
dass meine ausdauer so heftig ausdauer
stieg um 20 bp
nein das wäre natürlich sollte man das
wenn die beleuchtung kacke ist dann ist
kacke also wenn die so ist aber ich kann
das nicht so weg stellt ich kann diese
softbox nicht darüber erhöht ist das
wilde tier gebissen
ich kann diese softbox von da nicht
darüber erstellen das ist es geht nicht
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ein 2 2
das kind im flughafen du siehst du mich
auf der karte wer du bist viel direkter
lass mich rein nein alter habe ich jetzt
mein gott du bist draußen was mit einer
karre passiert aber ich habe einfach mal
den song für dich geklärt du willst
aussteigen heute kann er mit der
aufsteiger steckte nicht aus dem auto
da die böden sind unter tieren mit dem
flughafen keiner sucht mich ja ich
tauche auch jetzt und dann hab ich zu
bringen oder wartet wenn die piloten
wenn ich mich doch suchen kann mich im
arsche kein auto dann kann ich mir das
polizeiauto ist die sind und die man
hier ich bin ins hafenbecken
die fahnen nur zu dir wie geil als
termin ressourcen flieger debatte warte
ich bin gleich da die polizei war mit
der liga zu dir dann richtig ab welche
doch ich habe sie schon los so dass
muslime auch hier hoch kommen kaluza
jahre weg
lichtjahre religion kennt da wo du eben
was und dann habe ich den song kaputt
gehauen deine neue heft dann wollte ich
gerade weil jetzt nix doch da darf noch
heftige gefechte halle da sind die
bullen sind die da ist man einfach den
dänen den ligacup dabei
beim start beim zaun ich bin ja schon
jetzt drin fluss zu fuß da das alles ein
bisschen naja kann denke ich häufiger
die flugzeug rampe hoch dann fange ich
gleich wieder runter siehst du dein
flugzeug das ein riesiges puzzle
wer sein geld wir müssen glaube ich erst
mal die leute da er oder da können wir
nicht rein oder ich versuche von einer
seite welche leute nicht ob es geht wenn
schon von der anderen seite
ich glaube aber ehrlich gesagt nicht
dass das geht
er ist nämlich keine treppe oder so
reagiert nicht geht nicht geht nicht
es geht nicht dass hubschrauber tiger
wir klären zum schraube da kommt man
safe rein was kommt jetzt
ja ich sehe dabei sein ja klar
und noch keine bullerei geistiger kommen
jetzt halten wir uns einfach nur
schrauber geiger kommt rein und keine
rolle reimer und keiner was man will ich
habe so eine überwachungskamera das ist
ja geil geil ist die frage irgendwo auf
dem hochhaus links sind und dann die
polizei
ich hab keinen scharfen private
radiosender
ich kann schiessen müssen fünf posten
die atlantis mal ganz kurz das ist es
und polizei alter lässt das mini das ist
es ist also eine statue
da kann man nicht fliegen das mal zu
diesen waffenladen gehen zum militär
bastings ich kann mir nicht mehr so
heftiges zu kommen welches level 55
ich würde das 20 warten wir die
autobahnkreuze von oben sieht so heftig
aus die stadt schießt du den waypoint
gibt uns natürlich keine strecke weil
wir kein auto sind aber wir können
einfach kompliziert mache weil ich
irritiert weil das ist seiner mit
shooting range also mit schießen
natürlich keiner waffe muss sogar einer
mission zu diesem jahr hin
meist ist dann nach staufen schön
gelandet alter geil wir haben einfach
einen heli man jetzt irgendwer den ihr
umfeld oder so bleibst du kurz im heli
okay du kannst ja auch waffen holen oder
die dann droppen und dann kann ich sie
aufnehmen ehrlich das geil ich hoffe ich
kriege irgendwie scharfschützen wäre ich
bin auch erst level 20 glaube ich schon
mal was man jedoch eine haftbombe
nochmal hier ein bisschen schlagstock
messe
mit ein bisschen show magazin alles
möglich kriegst du scharfschütze ja ich
krieg scharfschützen
aber ich muss mal gucken ob du mir die
an gruppen kannst und dann selber die
noch ein geheimnis
ich gebe das geld doch wieder da wird
viel asche von mir ne ich habe sogar ein
fallschirm jetzt ball dann springe ich
gleich raus
hast du manchmal übrigens gesagt wir
sind hässliche hektischer weil wir
500.000 warum das denn jeder kriegt das
weil der gta online am anfang scheiße
war weil ich das mit den jeweilig
hingekriegt haben sind wieder hektischer
das war einfach drauf auch wenn es nicht
gewollt hätte bis bekommen so wie kann
ich das ins stocken
ich glaube du kannst die waffe aus wenn
dann kreist rücken-probleme also l2 geht
nicht nein ich pflege so wir können uns
jetzt hochhaus nahe kommen jetzt die
reihen sich mal hinten rein hinten
kannst du dich auch nicht klein aus
scheiße ich wollte gucken riesig
sitzplatzkarten leisten läuft bei dir
vor da kannst du das überschießen oder
sieht ja ich konnte auch fangen von vorn
an schließen aber das ist okay
rollvi night alter des werkes und die
haben ohne sowie ins polizei kacke das
problem ist finde ich noch nicht mal bei
den heli kannst du uns genannten aber
schneller und die haben
aber wenn du jetzt raus springen
ich habe keinen ich reg mich raus ich
lange jetzt aber ich hab's doch wir
schon wieder den eine tür auf zweck der
in berlin
mein gott könnte hier die avantgarde
wird ja es stimmt übrigens gegnern zu
tun
einer ist schwerer als man denkt
das ist das salz aus alters- rossi ok
wird so aber ich würde sagen wir machen
ganz kurz erstmals hat damit den ganzen
sachen die abspeichern und in der
nächsten folge werden wir dann von hier
oben vielleicht bullen abknallen
vielleicht auch runterspringen
vielleicht noch irgendwo anders hin
fliegen vielleicht mal in die wüste
fliegen bisschen kacke machen und dann
würde ich sagen es euch gefallen hat
könnt ihr das video bewerten und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder ciao
ciao